luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the leia highway pun show as you can see i
have a really great guest today previous cto of
coinbase entrepreneur angel investor previously
and um anderson horowitz it is biologist biologist
how you doing hey how are you doing yeah i'm good
thank you before we jump in i just want to let
everybody know that um this is powered by icon
plus capital the vc firm also sponsored by
block fi so you can actually get up to 250
dollars when you sign up which is pretty cool
because they offer really great interest rates
um and if you are watching on youtube please
don't forget to um subscribe hit the like button
so you never miss a brilliant guest so biologists
welcome to the show where are you based right
now uh undisclosed location but i'm in asia okay
okay cool and when i was doing loads of research
um trying to figure out okay you know what we're
gonna talk about um there's so much to discuss
with you you have so many interesting opinions on
many different topics um a lot of opinions which
i share so i'm gonna i figured i'd sort of just
free flow with this and kind of see where we land
i want to go back a bit you were the previous
cto of coinbase how did you get into this space
um so i've been interested in this kind of stuff
for a long time you know i um i was you know
i learned about uh you know the fed and other
types of stuff from ron paul in the 2000s but
um you know i always thought that in the fed
was idealistic but a little impractical and
then i really understood it much more after the
financial crisis and even still you know the fed
is at it's like the center it's this hub with
literally millions of spokes coming into it so
just in the fed i don't think was practical but
to exit the fed and build like an alternate hub
like over here that was um that had a bunch of
connections coming into it like what bitcoin is
that actually would be practical and so you know
like basically when bitcoin uh you know came out
there's a lot of things that are on one's radar
i really started paying much more attention to it
after it recovered from the crash in prices uh
the first one like it went up to 32 dollars in
the 2011 crash down to two but then it recovered
up and so i got much more heavily into it around
that time and i actually taught a stanford class
starting in late 2012 early 2013 that included
bitcoin as a component i still have some of my
lectures from that online and uh and then of
course bitcoin took off in a huge way in 2013
and uh you know that pulled me into the space
basically full-time for essentially the last eight
years i think a lot of venture capital and other
things on the side but let's say the through line
for the last eight years has been cryptocurrency
and it's changed so much since then but not
just this space but the world has changed
and you have this um sort of orwellian kind
of perception of how the world is right now
um and i i i sort of share that to an extent
so i just want to understand why you have that
perception what is it that's going on in this
world right now that makes you think oh god
you know we're going down a bit of a dark path
well i i would basically say i might slightly
rephrase to say it's not so much that it's
my perception is that the world is in some
ways becoming morbidly not so much that you know
like i i i desire an orbital kind of thing yes
so what's interesting is yeah so basically i
actually think it's kind of bimodal you know that
that uh tale of two cities you know thing you know
it was the best of times it was the worst of times
um i think what's happening is all the futures
are happening right the extreme dystopian
cyberpunk surveillance state you know where
you know drones whiz by overhead everything is
tracked uh and you know you have to barcode scan
to enter a store um and you know somebody can hit
a button and pull up everything you can be deleted
from the internet i mean you know you could have
cash that can be deleted from your account
unfortunately all those things that i've just
described either happened or are on pace to have
okay uh you know china is a sneak preview of some
of these things some of these things are happening
in the u.s et cetera so that kind of total state
sort of thing is also happening on the other hand
you have extreme points of light right we have
you know things like um you know boom supersonic
is you know finally getting supersonic aircraft
again we have um you know what what technology
is doing in terms of you know i'm actually a big
booster of biomedicine such as vaccines but
artificial eyes cochlear implants to restore
hearing the life extension stuff is moving along
um we have lots of discoveries in biomedicine like
you know restoring muscle and things like that
myostatin and things i've tweeted about um and
of course there's cryptocurrency and automating
wall street and you know replacing the fed with
you know digital gold something that they can't
print uh and you know there's there's drones and
there's autonomous robotics there's so many good
things happening where you have a possible vision
of a society where we've actually eliminated a lot
of sources of scarcity that plagued us of which
the most important is scarce life but you have
both of those things happening at the same time
and actually peter thiel you know it's funny he
had a very prussian remark 10 years ago where you
know at the time i thought it was just kind of a
projection of his personality but maybe it's just
one of those things where oftentimes the things
that tech people do everybody else does 5 or 10
or 20 years later right yeah teal basically said i
think it was 2009 that uh the world is in a deadly
race between politics and technology and that the
the race may be very close even down to the wire
and that the future may depend on the efforts of
one person who makes the world safer capitalism
this was two months after satoshi nakamoto had
put up the you know bitcoin genesis block at the
time nobody really knew how big it was going to be
perhaps other than you know satoshi or hal finney
but you know like what peter was thinking about
was patrick friedman's work on sea setting which
is actually i think also very important in the
fullness of time will become very important
um is very important it's got a longer burn but
satoshi was basically that person i think who made
the world safer capitalism the point being you
know tl why did he talk about this this like down
to the wire kind of thing part of it is due to
his experience at paypal where he closed a funding
round for paypal like a few days before the
dot-com crash happened it was very much down to
the buyer and because of that paypal is you know
like whatever billion dollar company today it's in
the tens i haven't checked the latest valuation
it's like a massive company today it obviously
influenced bitcoin it influenced stripe influenced
basically every fintech company um and it gave
birth to entire paypal mafia which was you know
reed hoffman and keith for boy and max lovechin
and all these guys who've done linkedin and square
like just this absolutely incredible diaspora
but it could all have died had he not closed that
round literally the day before the thing collapsed
right he just felt something that made him
push you know and so so that model of the world
is something which i find really interesting and
you know as i said at the time i thought it's
just because of peter's personal experience that
he projected that but it seems that projection
is correct and perhaps the high upside high
downside lifestyle of the tech entrepreneur
became more common and more common still such
that that becomes basically everybody's lifestyle
and is becoming everybody's lifestyle today
with all the pros and cons of that go ahead
yeah i mean so you i want to go back a second
because you mentioned china and you sort of said
that this orwellian state hasn't fully arrived
but you feel it could be coming we could be going
down that direction and you do speak a lot about
being this freedom maximalist freedom of speech
you don't necessarily call yourself a bitcoin
maximalist but it's freedom maximalism um so
in terms of what you feel is coming here what
would you say is because i know you said that
it's we're sort of seeing them a mirror of it
of what could be in china whether it's you know
policing of speech um you know policing of um i
guess you're sort of saying that we we see this
a bit in the cryptocurrency community as well like
this vocism policing of what you can and can't say
yeah so so on that basically um i think it's
not just uh i think in many ways unfortunately
i tweeted about this a while ago but i think it's
even more evidence today in many ways actually
um ccp and nyt are on a convergence right why
do i say mit because they're the ones who were
kind of pushing for a lot of the stuff in
the us government and actually a lot of
major tech companies are downstream of them and
so i kind of think of a triangle as you know uh
communist capital woke capital crypto capital
like these are three points on this triangle
and you know so communist capital is ccp it's
very simple it is you must submit okay total state
been before the communist party and then you can
go and make money not too much nowadays make too
much you'll get on the radar so that actually that
ceiling is descending quickly right um but that's
basically their social contract right they don't
have the concept of like quote limited government
or even the rhetoric around it that is there
west it's basically marxist-leninist you know uh
they're like uh agent smith from the matrix right
a chair can turn into a communist party guy if
they wanted to right like you can be interrogated
for violent law right or what they've decided as
a law so long as you don't contest their power
it's actually extremely straightforward then
you know you can basically just go about your life
you know make money you know have family whatever
right that's their social contract i'm saying it's
good obviously if you're a weaker that's not the
social contract but that's essentially how like
you know the let's say you're your defender or
even your neutral person the regime would tend to
express it okay now world capital is another poll
and world capital is you must sympathize and
the difference is with the the ccp they say
um that they are powerful and therefore that's
why you must submit with world capital it says
something different says you are powerful because
you are white because you are male because you are
straight because you are cis because you made some
money or because you're x or y or z some immutable
characteristic or some hard to change
characters because of that characteristic
you are powerful and therefore you must
apologize and what's interesting is both the ccp
and the bulk you know like like even though
they come at it from very different points
they end with downcast office right like you
know ccp is you must submit cash your eyes down
volt capital says you're powerful so you
must apologize again cast your idea so both
fundamentally ideolog ideologies of submission
um though the world version of it is much more
subtle right it's not that subtle but it's more
responsible right uh it's it's not that subtle
today but i think articulating in this way is it's
fundamentally something where you can throw out
somebody to get them to bend right bend their
head okay now the third pole is and by the way
will capital i don't think of it as fundamentally
driven by the state per se it's really driven by
legacy you know media corporations i've argued
especially nyt as a primary expense of this paul
graham actually retweeted something you know a few
years ago tweeted out which you can probably find
on twitter if you do from colon paul g space
hypothesis and uh you know he shows that um
a bunch of woke words just kind of rose
vertically actually i'm not sure if you can
project this uh on screen here we go i found
it oh i don't know if i can unless i don't
think you can okay words like is it words like i
don't know um hypothesis although some newspapers
can survive and switch to online subscriptions
none can do it and remain a politically neutral
newspaper of record you have to pick a side to
get people to subscribe and the thing is if you
look at this you basically see all these words
and phrases that we've used before just going
completely vertical and it has controls also
it has things like china or amazon where you'd
sort of expect them to be on an exponential
or general motors it's kind of coming down
right but you know like uh like white privilege
just totally vertical right white national park
i'm just going to say some words so people know
because they won't be able to see it so you've
got misogyny sexist patriarchy mansplaining
toxic masculinity male privilege feminism
women empowerment racism institutional racism
transphobia homophobia islamophobia hate speech
hurtful offensive triggering traumatizing all
of the ongoing that we have these days all the
stuff and the thing is that basically what that
coincides with is 2013 which is you know my uh my
friend arm saved had a very trenching observation
which is uh racism wasn't a new problem but the
new york times declining stock price in 2012 was
like if you go and look at their stock price okay
that's the thing you look at their stock price
and around that time the washington post had been
sold for basically fire sale prices to business
right it looked like media was down on one knee
uh you know tech had taken all this revenue from
them there's a great uh chart if you google tech
media you know print disruption essentially print
dropped from like about 67 billion in revenue to
like 18 billion revenue over four years after the
financial crisis and google and facebook and the
iphone all went vertical like this and that's why
you know bezos could buy the washington post this
great crown jewel not with the not with amazon.com
but out of his own pocket right petty cash he
had 250 to spend on this thing right so this
was like a humiliating moment guys like jack
schaefer were calling on salzburger for example
the salzburger family johns of times to sell
the new york times right and in this moment you
know what they basically did uh whether you know
did i put it all on them no you know there's
there's aspects of this sort of bubbling on
tumblr and you know gawker and you know
something awful and you know there's also
a political campaign waged in 2012 that pushed
a bunch of these buttons in order to i think get
out the vote right so all those things were there
but what happened was just like a restaurant owner
might spike their food with sugar and salt
large portions which um make them more profit
and you have a short-term engagement with the
store because you're eating more it's tastier etc
long-term however the externalizing the healthcare
cost the diabetes or the the heart disease or what
have you onto you right like the the eater in the
same way what happened in 2013 is they started
spiking the media diet your information diet
with these nerve jangling words and phrases that
just agitate right they polarize and they get hate
clicks on both sides and uh and you know what like
if it bleeds it leads if it enrages it engages
now i want to be clear that certainly tech is not
not to blame for this the social media environment
also was set up for this basically when two people
punch each other out on twitter over some news
story who profits linksy media corporations and
social media companies right they get i don't know
10 bucks and clicks for two people like stabbing
each other's reputation online it's like a boxing
promoter has two people knock each other's you
know brains out and they make money right and so
so essentially what has happened is over the last
eight years legacy media and social media have
literally made billions of dollars while they
like rent society to shreds and all the social
trust has gone down right so this is basically now
and then into that place when trust
is low the total state steps in right
so that's kind of both nyt itself and world
capital but let me come back to this triangle
right so with um you know the world capital poll
what's interesting is despite claiming some huge
rhetorical difference you know from china there's
a lot of convergence of the two you know i tweeted
this like i think two or three years ago um
let me see if i can find this uh let's see
some weird ways about you know china yeah here
we are neither side wants to admit it but uh
the us and china are converging in some weird
ways internet censorship nationalism and
socialism state takeover of tech companies social
credit versus cancel culture human flesh search
and twitter mobs right so just to define some
of those things you know everyone's like oh
my god it's so dystopian the chinese have the
social credit system canceled culture is just
a decentralized version of the same thing
that's one way of thinking about it right
and you know when uh with real consequences
people get banned from platforms or
de-platformed and just so happens that
all the companies do it at the same time
right so china is centralized censorship by the
state it's like overt and in your face right
in in the in the in the us because of the first
amendment what has evolved is a totally different
system uh that's very substantively similar
namely decentralized censorship by tech companies
okay and uh you know the third poll which i'll
get to is decentralized censorship resistance by
bitcoin encrypted protocols okay but another thing
i mentioned human flesh search and twitter mobs
so human flesh search is a concept in
china which is basically like a twitter
mob hunting for somebody online to find that
they said something awful right now the exact
moral things you can get canceled for in china
are very different than in the us like in china
it's something related to taiwan in the us it's
you know it was saying like latinx or something
stupid like this you know which yeah actually
hispanic people don't say it you know yeah um
and uh so it so differs or if you're not saying
latinx um it differs but the substance is similar
okay should i get to the third pole cryptocurrency
yeah yeah yeah all right so just jump in any time
because i i will i will go okay all right no
okay fine i'll jump in after the third pole gone
okay great so the third fold just to recap we
have um ccp we have let me do it so this is a
mirror okay it's all mirror image uh we have ccp
right we have ccp we have nyt and then we have
btc okay those are like the three poles right
communist capital will capital cryptocapital if
communist capital says um you must submit and vote
capital says you must sympathize cryptocapital
says you must be sovereign okay so the other
two tell you that you have to bow your head
this actually says you have to hold up your
chin okay now there's a lot of good in this
right there's a lot of obligation in this you have
to hold your own private keys you have to you know
like basically think for yourself when it comes to
for example food rather than eating carbohydrates
you have to realize actually the things that
society advises you to do like take out the you
know 30-year mortgage or you know be in debt for
the rest of your life in student loans the debt is
actually pretty bad in general and that you should
prefer equity and saving money to getting this
debt that uh you know things like um you know the
food pyramid as i mentioned like these things are
wrong and uh it's a lot of good to this right the
issue is it even that can be taken to an extreme
because if you you know if you're if everybody
has to be sovereign for everything at all times
there is no uh there's no collective action
there's no shared goods there's no community
of any kind in extremis for example um you know
people actually just as a thought experiment if
there was no ability whatsoever to regulate food
and drugs you would have to basically bring your
own portable dipstick into starbucks to kind of
poke it into the coffee to make sure that there
wasn't some you know bad thing in there right that
sounds like a caricature but this is actually why
people in china for example often buy food
from the west because they don't actually trust
like chinese baby formula you know after some
scandals like melamine and so on there right so
that might that might sound like a caricature and
certainly relative to you know america's fda you
know we could we could do something better with
better type one and type two you know rates but
in practice what people actually want is a quote
regulated marketplace in the sense of an actor
that gives star ratings of you know actors and
it bans bad actors what's my point basically
um the form of that regulator doesn't necessarily
have to be a nation-state regulator it can be an
internationalist capitalist regulator in a sense
ebay for example is a regulator of the marketplace
they give star ratings and ban bad actors right
um paypal has fraud reviews amazon has reviews
of books and they ban bad actors uh you know
uber and airbnb do the same thing these are
cloud regulators internationalist capitalist
regulators not nation state-based regulators
which achieve some of the same functions
and they do so in a competitive marketplace
where exit is the overall governor if you don't
like uber's regulation you go to lyft right if you
don't like airbnb's regulation there's other kind
of you know services that you can use point being
that uh the extremists of you must be sovereign
basically takes no regulation to the point of
denying that people actually want some kind of
third party quality control right they want to
contract somebody to do it they don't necessarily
want to do it themselves um but denying that that
even exists can be one failure another feeling
mode is on things like covet right where
um one of the things that's really difficult
that i find is unless you're a scientist right
and you know i have a background in genomics and
bioinformatics and what have you so i felt well
equipped to go and read the primary literature
read things with a grain of salt diligent things
say that's a bad paper that's a good paper
that's really interesting this maps what i know
but i have a lot of sympathy for people who you
know i don't know let's say let's say this was um
earthquake geophysics okay that
would be an area where i know
you know enough physics you know physics
of waves and so on to probably get into it
but would i be able to you know really get
in there right away and look at the data
not at the same level right not as it not as much
as environment experience so i'm very sympathetic
to people who are caught between either zero
trust or total trust right and most people
can't have like intermediate levels of trust in
something their trust is either broken or it's
or it's present you know and so what happened
with the government is when they went and um i
mean with the u.s government western governments
when all this official misinformation came out
masks don't work before they do cova's contained
and now it's there everybody has to stay at home
but you can go out to protest but you have
to see hello but the governor doesn't have to
people can see the inconsistencies on this
and so i'm sympathetic to those people who
just now distrust the state but that's a
failure mode of you must be sovereign because
we're just social animals we can't all figure it
out for ourselves so what i think about is what i
call the decentralized center okay so in these
kind of three poles of this triangle right prc
nyt btc you want the decentralized center where
it is you know it's not exactly moderates because
it's going to be quite different from like the
moderate world of you know 1990 or 1980 it's
a different kind of center but it's something
which is like you you have a society that takes
the the people who were exiled from each of these
three kind of quadrants right the people jack ma
right who in china you're not just jack ma but all
the hundred thousand whatever entrepreneurs and
crypto chinese who exist by the way there's not
just communications the script of chinese people
who are much like you and i with similar morales
they just live in china right so we shouldn't just
think of it all being bad people there's a lot of
you know a lot of very good people there right i
mean it's obvious point but some of the rhetoric
around it i think says the chinese doing this the
chinese doing that i think it's important to send
your ccp from your average chinese person many of
whom are very cosmopolitan and positive some so so
something you want something which is appealing to
them you want something that's appealing to people
who are tolerant but not book and you want people
something that's appealing to people who are
libertarian but not you know in favor of crypto
anarchy right now why do i say that right crypto
anarchy is cool but i prefer crypto civilization
okay crypto anarchy you know what that is yeah
yeah yeah okay so crypto energy for your viewers
and by the way again jump in because i'll just
go okay okay we actually i'm going to go back
then half a second though because i don't go too
far just yet just pause on the crypto anarchy i
just want to focus on okay i just want to focus
on the whole idea of this woke culture just for
a second um because it's not so obvious to some
people and for me whenever i'm looking online
and i'm reading twitter and i see tweets like
yours um people who share similar ideas it's
always really refreshing and i don't understand
why um because you said it's a bit more subtle
um compared to the ccp which isn't so subtle for
me it's the same thing it's just different right
like it's communism and it's exactly the same
thing and it's what's coming over here to the west
but it's done with this whole um you know you
must admit because um you know you're privileged
and it's not fair and we've got to help and
we've got to be kind it's come come from a
more moral standpoint so my question is why isn't
it so obvious because you kind of brush past this
as if it's so obvious as if you know yeah we
can easily compare this to the ccp and what's
happening there but it's not so obvious to some
people even in the crypto community it's not so
obvious people wearing masks and things like that
in like profile pictures and and all these things
you know like there's a lot of signaling going
on and it's not always so obvious to people so
why would you say that that it is a bad thing okay
great question so first one thing i would observe
so actually david shore was a pretty smart guy
on the you know democrat side you know i wouldn't
consider myself to have any political labels but
uh he i was able to actually note something after
the election that most people wouldn't be able to
know which is actually um the democrats actually
gained in the white vote and uh republicans
actually gained on the minority side right which
okay well so that's contrary to a lot of the
narrative or what have you and uh what what i
think is interesting about this is i think we're
starting to see something which is sort of like
um the like these extremely woke white people
who are expecting sins real or imagined for you
know inheriting money or something like that
like a lot of these people are like choked
and and exert whatever grads and you find that
it is the privileged whites who call out quote
other people's white privilege the most right the
privileged concern with other people's privilege
and this is a weird form of expediting their
own guilt because they know that they inherited
something they didn't found it but the way they
execute that guilt is conveniently by tearing down
other people right by tearing down you know some
poor southern guy or some guy in the west or you
know some some plumber in new york as being white
privileged as if they actually were you know going
to exeter and church and and so on and so forth
right um so that's one aspect of it the second
aspect is uh that you know people like you know
yourself or myself who have some intersectional
credential right like you know being non-white or
a woman or what have you right and actually that's
a vast majority of the world if you think about
it only something like depending on how you count
less than twenty percent of the world is white
i don't know the exact percent it's not like 80
is quote people of color right and then you
add women and so almost everybody has like some
intersectional credential okay yeah and uh because
of that we can sort of we have like some shield
or armor in this stupid social media game right
the third thing as to why this thing is popular
is um did you have a concept of immune escape for
viruses no okay so a virus can be targeted by like
a develop vaccine mutation that lets it wiggle
out of that yeah okay so you know essentially
it mutates and now it's escaped your immune
system or it's escaped the vaccine okay this
is actually something about the other day so if
you think of communism and localism is my viruses
okay basically i think it's actually this is
actually a very deep concept i'm going to go
deep on this for a second right but if you think
of those mind viruses yes localism has structural
similarities to communism okay uh but there's
some fundamental differences that have led immune
escape if you think about it the much of the world
was vaccinated against communism over the course
of the 20th century at the cost of 100 million
dead you know if you read you know seven countries
okay that's interesting so you're saying
we're we're vaccinated against communism
oh i see where you're going with this
i see where you're going with this okay
partially right but the thing is rocasim versus
communism so communism was a redistribution of
wealth vocalism is a redistribution of status
right communism was offensively for workers and
peasants vocalism is ostensibly for women
and minorities like yourself and myself
right communism was about the union strike and
wokeness is about the woke mob communism setting
was a factory floor and wokeness's setting
is social media and so the thing is why do
communism spread if you actually go back and look
at it i mean this thing started with a book and it
grew to control an enormous swath of the earth's
you know surface right the ussr china cuba like
this thing did appeal to people it did quote win
against you know more practical philosophies why
is that the case right and part of the reason is
it's not the only reason there's several reasons
part of that is the microeconomic incentives
for communism okay so that's to say if you were
uh like do you know how that is no okay so from
this book up to sinclair's book the jungle right
if you go and read that book you'll get a sense
of what attracted people to communism these guys
were working in factories they were going to this
wrenching transition of the industrial revolution
uh they were alienated from their farms and
their homes you know sometimes children were
being worked really hard there were disasters like
the triangle shirtwaist factory and so so much a
program was heaped on the unethical owner who had
all this leverage and could you know bankrupt you
or you know put you out of work and you know the
the family farm that you wanted that was now being
bankrupted by these big factories that you know
or big you know industrial operations you just
couldn't you couldn't make it as a family farm
anymore right um all those were real things and so
uh you know the what happened was some guy came
into uh a factory and they basically say we've got
the answer it's communism and here's why you gotta
do you gotta do you build a union and do strikes
and then what do you do everybody here will get
some money why because you'll make that boss bend
that boss who's so powerful all of us together are
strong you know and we'll make him bend and now we
all get raises whoa oh my god the strike worked
holy cow and that would get reported in all the
communist papers and everybody would you know
like you know raise their fist oh we did it and
then the hangover the next day or the next week or
something happened because you'd have union dues
right that would actually be coming out of your
paycheck that was increased now it's decreased you
have a second boss which is like the union manager
on top of the other manager right you suddenly
have speech and thought controls so elia kazan
had this movie on this in the mid 20th century
called on the waterfront you ever heard of it no
okay worth watching simply to get a sense of that
time and place where basically you'd be canceled
for totally different things but essentially being
disloyal to the union or you know which
could expand into lots of things like being
working a little too hard you know and trying to
make us look bad you know all of those kinds of
things right you can start to see how that would
be cause for cancellation and you'd lose status
among the other workers and so the combination
all these things meant that your factory
your company became less competitive over time
but what you're basically doing with the strike is
debiting from the future um to build the president
now with that said strike is a pressure tactic
what the workers the communist workers thought
was happening at that time they thought it was a
zero-sum situation where the boss would would lose
and they would win it turned out to have to be a
negative some situation where they were actually
harming both parties over the long term including
themselves by making the company less competitive
but they didn't understand that because they could
only see it was a negative some situation with
a short-term positive gain it's like getting in
a very high interest rate credit card kind of
thing you get the money today it sort of tricks
the psyche right okay yeah so that's like part
of the microeconomics of it the other aspect
of course is the religious zeal you know nietzsche
wrote in the leading kindreds god is dead and what
he was observing was he wasn't actually invading
against god in that particular uh you know epistle
he was basically saying you know there's
enough educated people who don't believe
that um there's going to be wars beyond imagining
people are going to look to fill effectively that
god-shaped hole and what a lot of people did is
they filled their worship of god with gov right
with the government right the government can do
everything right there's an ad a while back which
was government is the thing we all belong to right
and so essentially people project onto it this
monotheistic thing of the all father right the
everything you know yeah and and so they basically
they're quote secular but they actually believe
in this thing as green lantern because it's like
the most powerful thing right they literally
worship you know the government right so there's
a second aspect in the vacuum of god people
projected all this power onto this thing okay
so these are some of the reasons communism
spread now let's bring it to lopez right
wokeness um has done immune escape it doesn't
look exactly the same so for one thing basically
i don't know the hard hat right was 1971 no
i'm saying no to everything my god what is that
so the hard hat right is 1970 actually so that was
actually the flip okay basically for essentially
about 17 something actually around 100 years the
the working man and his noble nature that was
essentially like the backbone of communist you
know revolutions all across the world right
yeah yeah but in 1970 an important flip happened
where union workers in the us came out to
beat up the hippies who were protesting against
the vietnam war which meant that union workers
had basically been cut in to american prosperity
enough that they didn't feel alienated like the
guys from 50 years ago right this by the way you
know rather than the the win-lose situation or the
negative some situation the win-win situation
is exploitative boss right the negative some
situation really lose lose uh is is a union strike
the win-win is actually aligned capitalism right
so the way to meet communism in the past the way
that actually worked was aligned capitalism where
to avoid this negative some situation where you as
a ceo or the executive are harmed and your workers
are harmed even if the strike organizers don't
get it you cut them in on the pot this all should
eventually lead to startups and equity shares
and so on and so forth where you're not seeing
that you are aligned you're proving it by giving
them a slice right i'll come back to this point
but basically that was actually i think the
solution now this is actually working well enough
now let me also give an asterisk because i know
some people are going to say that was working
well until 1971 we got off the gold standard
then workers were no longer given such a cut
i agree i'll come back to that but let's just
say take it back to 1970 okay so 1970 these uh
the hard hat riot these guys uh the the union guys
went out and beat up the hippies and many people
realized wait a second the host for the mind
virus is no longer these white working class guys
so now they were like considered the most noble
thing in the freaking world for basically 70 years
right uh more than that like 100 something years
that like every all the bloodshed everything was
for them the working man and so on and so forth
right and and all the faults were airbrushed now
we suddenly saw a mirror image where this guy
who is super noble became archie bunker and all
his negative traits were stressed the racism the
sexism the homophobia these are caricatures that
you know like probably some troops just there's
probably some truth to the the you know the
working man being oppressed by those boss in some
way but these aspects now were stressed and it was
flipped and so the person who is to put the hero
of the communist revolution became the villain
of oldness and the my virus switched hosts to
now right so that's actually a very important
thing right if you think about how how much
essentially the modern you know like works beat
up on the white working class as being benighted
and you know conservative and so on and so forth
that's a really important thing and you know
so in that flip other things happen as well the
oppressed class theory switched from you know
economics and you know workers and peasants
to women and minorities right the now with
wokeness now studying wilderness for a second
why does it spread how how does something so
irrational spread well now we go to social media
rather than the factory floor the microeconomic
incentives for wokeness are very simple
if you say that somebody is mansplaining or you
know something like this so much i hate that time
i know because it basically is something
which essentially delegitimizes on the order
of 50 of the world because of their immutable
characteristics but it's not that though it's not
that it's not that like really cruel makes my skin
cruel it's kind of just like the hypocrisy of it
because like it's still an offensive word
like to say that like if somebody said you're
lazy splaining i would be like oh i'm doing
what like it just it's it's it's it's it's
ironic it's hypocritical because you're saying
that he's being sexist by using a sexist term
but the thing with with it spreading which which
which you know we can get to i think it was yuri
besmanov who said that you will people will never
know what's arrived so you and i know probably
most of people listening and watching know but i
think he says you won't know what's arrived until
you have physical harm inflicted on you that's
what he said so if we take like covert for an
example i don't really i don't at this point i
don't really care what's happening you know like i
don't really care whether it's real it's not real
whether the numbers have been inflated whether
masks work or not i don't care at this point
it's been 18 months and i just think we should
all have our freedom back um but this is for me
a prime example of what's happening and even now
despite so in the uk our news it goes back and
forward how many died how many haven't died it's
very contradictory the data and everything even
the rules across the world are contradictory
where masters inside don't wear masks inside
wear them outside don't wear them outside
so even now given everything that's happened
with our civil liberties being taken away
people still are really blind to what's
happening and he says your resume says
until you are you actually have pain inflicted
on you it's kind of like walking to um walking to
i don't like to use this term but like walking
to the like the gas chambers blind basically
it's not until you're sort of there that
you'll really be able to see what's happening
um i don't know if you do do you have an opinion
on that do you think you know as this is spreading
people aren't going to wake up
until you know communism really hits
so a couple of thoughts on this so basically um
yeah it obviously doesn't have to be something as
severe as you know the holocaust but it could
just basically be a breakthrough your window
actually you know with the with um on the on the
total reverse of that like some of the anti-israel
stuff recently has gotten extreme and that was a
shift that wasn't obvious until this recent event
where people were you know smashing windows
and stuff and hitting people in the street
um a couple of thoughts on this so first on covet
you know in general my stance on covet is i would
say the asian stance where it just hasn't been
politicized in the same way it has in the west
and the response in general has been much
more competent like if you look at a world map
of you know deaths and so on from covet for the
most part asia especially east asia you know like
has has done quite well and i would include
actually australia and new zealand in this
now what we'll come to is people say oh well
they're islands well the uk is also an island
something about the pacific rim and the cultural
influence there meant that people just kind of
took this as a public health thing and then they
didn't lie to the citizens about masks don't work
before they do and all the stuff you know that
that's there but they also validate the citizens
trust by keeping the thing under control you
know and so if you ask for the ball you've
got a dunking right if you ask for the trust you
actually have to validate the trust and for the
most part pacific rim governments actually did
better now the reason i say that is i think of
that as a third position which is something
which is not i think the silly politicized
thing that's happened in the west i'm sympathetic
to your view i'm also similar to the view of
somebody who's had somebody die from covenants who
thinks it is very serious it's like a fractal kind
of thing where there's enormous variability in
outcomes per person there's you know like this is
something which root causing the noise is actually
quite difficult part of that is probably due to um
immunogenomics let's say some people simply have
more susceptibility than others right part is due
to things like diabetes or being overweight part
of this due to which variant you get all this type
of stuff what that results in though is a highly
stochastic environment where people have different
micro environments of what information they
receive and what they've seen on covet what tracks
their personal experience and so i'm completely
sympathetic by the way to the idea that this has
been used by western governments to erode freedoms
um i also think that you know this is something
that has killed whatever millions of people around
the world so it's like a real virus and it's a
base that could get more serious that's to say
like started out pretty bad and could get worse
now the problem is that that kind of position
is i would argue like a rational position
but people want to bucket you into one or two
camps in the west because that's where most
people are reasonably so right so that's
kind of my position on covid um it is uh
it's something which i think is like um you know
most people weren't prepared for 10 years of iraq
most people aren't prepared for 10 years of covet
the bad thing about it is going to be all the
surveillance stuff that we've got when i say 10
years ago what i mean i say there's a possibility
not a probability but a possibility that uh there
if you're if you're looking at some of the work
i'm looking at that there's immune escape you
know like essentially efficacy versus vaccines
coming down um the flu has a totally different
you know uh architecture at the genetic level it
won't be super technical but has a different
architecture which makes it more immutable
however it looks like covet is managing to
do some immune escape there's websites like
next train and so on the track what's that
likely to result in probably booster shots
every x number of months that of course won't
be taken by people um and uh so so i you know
it's just something where there'll be a fracturing
of society on this i think that over time the the
one good thing that comes out of this uh that
i'm seeing is sort of a y-shaped recovery where
there's much more investment in fitness tracking
in home gyms in personal health in glucose meters
and all that type of stuff because i think that's
the thing that people can agree on which is i want
to track my own health i don't want i don't trust
the cdc or the fda or the uk equivalent sarah
right go ahead yeah you say that but you know
you're talking about people actually wanting
to take personal responsibility over their health
and um home gyms and all that but i just disagree
i think we're moving down a path of laziness where
nobody wants to take responsibility for anything
of course people do but i'm i'm just generalizing
um you know i think in in america they were sort
of saying we'll give you a free donut if you come
take a vaccine i mean like this is a public health
thing i didn't see that yeah yeah yeah it's
just like open the damn gyms like go okay go
say if you go to the gym and you do a good workout
we'll you can have the vaccine you know i'm just
it it to me to me it's all just very strange and
i think we are moving down this um i wouldn't
say dystopian future or this dystopian path
because i do agree with you that there is
a lot of plus sides to things especially with
technology and cryptocurrency and i think that
one of the questions somebody actually asked was
um ask biologists what he thinks some of the um
key skills people need um to survive the
next two decades because like you said
i do think covered will be a decade situation like
let's just say brexit as an example as a british
person that went on for four or five years um
this is this is going to be a decade thing i don't
think it's going to be as difficult as the last 18
months have been but it's a lot of the stuff isn't
going to go um so how do we from an entrepreneur's
standpoint how do we survive the next
20 years because jobs that people are doing now
will become majorly redundant for many different
reasons whether it's tech or whether it's covered
whatever it is that's right so basically like
you know what is my ideal right my ideal is
a um you know so to caricature right this
is a caricature but uh the democrat wants more
government the republican wants less government
uh the libertarian wants no government and the
technologist wants a new government right how
to start a new country how to start new
states you know and so uh the reason i
think about this is i think that what we're in
the middle of is essentially the unbundling and
rebundling of legacy nation states um if you
know if you think if you think 2020 was lit
you know i think the 2020s are going to be liter
okay so to speak um and what i mean by that is
uh the shocks of the system you know the 2001
you know like 9 11 attacks the 2008 you know
financial crisis 2020 you know corona and so on
these are you know like essentially like a larger
and larger and larger ruptures right that they
do die down you know in the sense of like like
resources are thrown at them they die down but
a new normal is attained right the new normal of
surveillance the new normal like you know post 9
11 obviously way more surveillance post 2008 all
of these like you know financial regulations and
so on in place post 2020 right much stuff but also
a new level of resistance to that you know yeah
and um so so it's like pushing in both sides of
high centralization and decentralization and um
so i think this is like the story of the century
that fight between centralization
and decentralization i think that
um you know you ask what should your viewers or
whatever do so for those who can i would say learn
computer science and statistics and i really
mean that okay why because those are general
okay general cells like just what physics was
to the early 20th century of course physics is
still valuable you should learn physics it's great
okay um however what's interesting is think about
okay let me ask you a question what percentage
of your time do you spend looking at a screen
too much too much let's say 80 i don't know
80 percent it's terrible it's really bad okay
so here's the thing most of the rest of
your life will be spent in the matrix
okay okay meaning like most of your waking
hours are being spent in an artificial
virtual constructed world it's on a screen today
it'll be in vr or ar glasses or something like
that tomorrow that's where the economy is going
that's where all of these things are going you
know have you tried oculus quest 2 no okay it's
worth trying because it's actually really good
like let's say you know it's actually immersive
in a really interesting way you forget that you're
in physical space you need a dime like that for
example shiv is thinking about it fine so there's
also ar glasses that just give an overlay on the
world so you still know where you are right um
and there'll be other kinds of things like this
one are you thinking about it is um when are you
born 1990 something like that uh a little earlier
yes yes let's say something in the 90s probably
okay it's okay i'm a 90s baby yeah fine fine okay
so you know at that time each day you could count
how many communications electronic communications
you initiated and most of the time it was zero
right like we remember a time before the internet
now today you cannot count how many electronic
communications you've initiated because you know
like the number of packets we're sending back and
forth here if you have a fitbit if you have this
you get that you're just constantly sending these
electron communications and you know this is also
going to be happening with transactions like the
number of electronic transactions you're sending
your economic complexity is rising um oops i'm
still i'm still here yeah it's just my camera okay
yeah so so essentially like the the virtual world
that we all live in is just like building up like
virtual girders building around and um people are
going to spend way more time there for several
reasons first the devices are improving okay yes
um we're going to a world where physical is a
premium product or maybe are arguably already
there what i mean by that is in the 1990s you
know there's this concept of digital divide you
remember that no i was a baby in the 1990s okay
all right so 1990s essentially the idea was um
you know some people aren't online there's
a digital divide they're not advantageous
now today we actually are starting
in western countries you know like
like basically countries that have internet
penetration we're trying see the physical divide
where um it's cheap to put you know millions
of transistors you know on on a chip but it's
expensive to put thousands of people in a room
right physical is becoming expensive physical is
becoming a premium product for several different
things okay number one for example plant travel
zoom is much faster than the you know like
basically anything that you do you do digital
first right communication are you writing
a physical letter you're writing a message
every single thing that you can think of if you
can do digital first is cheap because it's just
electrons weren't right okay number one number
two is ai is coming online in a really big way
so sam altman who's you know my colleague
actually tweeted something like this that
he thinks a lot of things jobs that are done on
the screen the price of them is going to deflate
drop very fast faster than actually offline things
like plumbing and so on until robotics gets good
that will cause some weird things i was coming
in from a third direction which is in the event
that inflation happened so i was coming out
from the crypto rather than the eye direction
in the event that inflation happens it will
disproportionately hit physical things you know
my arguments why can you can you guess it it will
it will disproportionately hit physical things why
because lumber or you know oil or food those are
physical goods and scarce but the marginal cost of
serving you another file from dropbox is not that
much so it might you know going from point zero
zero zero zero one cents even 10xing that is not
really that noticeable if the marginal costs are
low right so as the world outside becomes more
and more and more expensive and the digital
world becomes cheaper thanks to ai and uh you know
because everybody's got these phones and so on you
have something where physical becomes a premium
product and more and more life is spent basically
in the matrix now i recognize there's lots of bad
stuff about that world okay um however uh and i
think that we can use that world to break out into
a better physical world or come back to that point
however in the intervening period of like
digital first physical as a premium product um
you want to learn computer science and stats
because that's how you shape what's on screen
computer science is the algorithms and
data structures and stats is how you do
calculations on those data structures cisco
analysis thereof any anything you know tesco
i know that's a big shock in the big business
in the uk you go into tesco you know cs and
stats they can point you to the database you can
add value you want to go to boeing you can add
value you go to pfizer you can add value everybody
has algorithms and data structures and so that's
a way a lens of looking at the world that's
going to give dividends for many years to come
yeah so just on that point where you say
that um you know everybody needs to start um
learning the new technical way computer science
and everything like that it makes me laugh
just because it reminds me of that meme
where people say learn to code right there
and it is a meme and it is funny because
not everybody can learn to code and this is
wait let me jump in on that so okay so
learn computer science and statistics or
learn to add value to somebody who can
okay but how do you how do you add value
when all your look like the man that's
60 70. how does he even men that are
i say men women as well sorry whatever but
even even people that are in their 40s now
or higher you know if they haven't grown up with
this new world of technology or aren't necessarily
in one one you know paying an interest in it when
they were much younger it's very difficult to make
that shift let's take truck drivers as an example
right 20 years ago you're a truck driver yes you
still had access to um you still had access to the
internet and social media and all this stuff but
it wasn't really that hot um and you know you're
not really going to start learning to code at 40
50. you're just not especially 60 onwards so what
does that mean for a large portion of society and
i think it's andrew yang who's really big on this
he talks about um universal basic income because
it's not fair to some people that we are moving
into this futuristic um future if you like um so
what do we do because not everybody can actually
learn computer science and things like that i'm
naughty i'm not even techie i've been able to find
value in what i do which is great i'm not techy i
just have an interest in i'm just interested in
freedom to be honest and i like to speak so i've
done fine but what if other people can't do that
then what okay so several things the first is um
it's a multi-pronged answer uh so first they're
you know i'm investing in things like lambda
school there's also mavens other things like this
that actually are showing traction on retraining
um and they do so by basically just they take
like a walmart clerk who has enough persistence
and they train them to become an engineer
okay but how old are you talking though
in their 30s right so you know i actually i don't
know i i'm not i don't want to speak out of turn
i actually do not know the age distribution of
the people there right but i do know that they've
actually had significant success with folks who
are outside of traditional venues because um you
know one of the things they're doing is like
objective based learning where they just keep
they're like you will learn how to do this and
they just keep doing it over and over until
people get they debugged it over a lot of folks
that's lame school there's others okay but some
of the retraining stuff is starting to work uh and
and so i think that that's actually an important
piece number one basically if you think about it
with computers we should be able to do education
much better you can track all kinds of inputs
and outputs you can see whether someone's getting
problem right and what their stimulus was so
it's plausible that insofar as the brain itself's
computer that we can track io and apply that
computer science and systems to figure out how to
do the i o better okay you're basically installing
software let me come back to that by the way let
me bookmark and sort and software in the brain um
so one is i'm not totally giving up on returning
number two is ben harvest's point which is the
jobs of the future are harder to predict because
like we know what the jobs of the president are we
don't know the jobs of the future are if you think
about it like you know the industrial revolution
transition everybody bemoaned the transition from
the farm to the manufacturing floor now whatever
100 you know like about 100 years later people
bemoan the fact that manufacturing jobs are going
away right okay so what do i think you know if the
1800s was farming and the 1900s is manufacturing
what is the 2000s i actually think it's both
totally obvious and not obvious which is the 2000
this century is about investing let me explain
what i mean by that that's to say everybody
becomes an investor just like the the you know
social media turned everybody into a publisher
cryptocurrency is going to turn everybody into
an investor this is already happening um why
because okay maybe you agree right so great so
it's robin hood it's coinbase it's venture capital
it's angel investment it is you know the the um
i've seen like everything that you can do the
blockchain is defy it's all of the stuff right
and uh with you know concretely what that means is
a larger and larger percentage of people's income
is going to come from capital gains if you could
plot that i think that's going to start rising
okay um and you know there's an interesting flip
sometime by mid-century maybe sooner maybe later
where the 99 percent are capital and the one
percent are labor what i mean by that is so
that's a flip of the 20th century in the 20th
century you thought of like the investors being
rich and you know the worker is being poor right
capital where the one percent and labor is 99
in this century it may flip where everybody's an
investor but there's a tiny percentage of founders
who are able to take capital which is flowing
like water on this internet and turn it into a
useful product this by the way i think is one of
the least appreciated things lots of people think
that if you have money it's just click your
fingers and you can build a spaceship right
you click your fingers electric car right
or even you know like a genetic test
or or dropbox right it's not that easy uh if
you've ever done capital allocation of any kind
like actually running a business starting business
or anything it's just not something you can't buy
a spaceship off the shelf right it's people think
that because something is easy is easy or looks
easy that it was easy to build and it's not at all
right that interface the api if put in a dollar
put in a pound get back you know like a pencil as
that famous story goes you know like it's really
hard to create a pencil right you know what i'm
talking about from yeah yeah yeah yeah like the
lead and the pencil and the eraser yeah i know
everywhere and everyone does every part and yeah
exactly and the api is very simple which
is putting the money but the thing is
actually ridiculously complicated okay so so
i think that um everybody becomes an investor
you just have to click a button online on
robinhood on republic.com on angellist on
you know this or that app to invest nowadays
so it's similar to the experience of amazon
but it's very different because you know
it's in the game you're tracking it right
and there's huge downsides you know if you
think about for all the ceos or whatever
you know watching this like and a lot of ceos
have had like bad board members or something
think about the worst board member you've ever had
one one a thousand experts is a retail investor
right they're the most short-term flighty they
don't even know what the heck is going on most
of the time i'm synthetic to them of course but
we need to build structures that accommodate this
10 100 000 x increase and one of those things
is going to be provable on chain alignment so
people aren't quite scamming people or doing
short-term things you want long-term holding
you want like a thousand different on-chain
assertions um basically that decentralized
regulation uh that kind of i shouldn't say
replaces the ssc but becomes the exit to it right
an alternative that other countries can adopt you
know just like you could exit the fed right okay
so that's the second part of it everybody becomes
an investor that is something that everybody can
do um but you know it is quote gambling like in
the sense that you may or may not achieve a good
outcome all right what's the third thing um so
first is retraining second is everybody becomes
an investor and so it's a multi-part thing i'm not
seeing any one of these okay the third is there
are new jobs arising okay um you know you're an
influencer i'm not sure if you're a professional
influencer but that's basically what you know
i'm one might call you right something like 20
of america wants to grow up to be youtube stars
the reason that actually might be not as insane
as people think is there is an enormous amount
of time spent looking at screens our entire
consumption pattern has shifted content is
a larger larger percentage of the day it has
increased x so the market for content is increased
people are paying you know online for this content
now which they've learned 20 years ago so content
creation is a third thing which people can do and
why is that important because if you know one of
my sayings is code scripts machines media scripts
humans okay number three number four robotics
this is actually coming online in a big way so
if you look at vicarious.com if you look at boston
dynamics the robotic future is happening now we
need to push this farther faster okay why because
on the other side of the robotic transition you
have the hyper deflation of prices due to the fact
that lots of things can now be made by basically
uh electricity right you charge the robot what
you want to do the intervening thing will be very
destructive as lots of people are put out of work
but it's like the industrial revolution transition
you want to catch them with some other things okay
um so i mentioned retraining i mentioned everybody
becomes an investor i mentioned uh robotic
automation was number three what did i say
um number three uh you said retraining
everybody becomes an investor robotics
what was the fourth one uh there's another one
that i just mentioned i forget about come back to
um well content creation right oh content creation
yeah yeah yeah and you know the thing is that and
then number five is uh this is actually a big one
very good one um the the new blue collar you know
i don't really like this framing of it but i'll
use it because i don't have something better yet
the new white collar blue collar is like above
the api below the api have you heard this concept
before no i'm waiting to hear what you're going
to say if you're an uber engineer you're coding
the api and if you're an uber driver the api is
telling you right yeah this is like you know some
people frame this as incredibly dystopian and
bad i actually don't think it's that different
from a factory manager and an assembly line
worker if you romanticize manufacturing jobs
the api application is just like a decentralized
factory floor right it's like a bunch of people
are being given direction by manager but it's in
the form of code and it scales a little better
it's a little more you know um predictable
and so there's bad aspects obviously you know
the algorithm can can you know lower your prices
or search you or whatever in other ways but so
long as there's competition and that's what we
should want we should want competitive businesses
lyft we should want tesla's taxi services that
comes up then you have an equilibrium hopefully
that is reasonable so that's potentially a huge
catchment for a number of blue-collar workers yes
the factory worker may not become an engineer but
they certainly probably can become an uber driver
or something like that right okay so that's
five right six is the unknown the unknown is
like a very large category because predicting the
future in detail is not obvious if you told people
you know in in 1980 that you know like computer
engineer would be the most popular job in
you know 2020 like computers just weren't that
popular right a lot at the time you know steve
jobs was marketing computers like that early apple
mac and stuff around that time yeah yeah yeah
it was so limited in memory that he was
talking about using it for like storing recipes
okay now and because you could do computation
with it you could store recipes the
internet connectivity wasn't there
games really weren't that impressive
and there's some stuff it was okay but you really
had to believe in this computer thing right to
think that it would be such a large potential
economy you have to have some vision right
so six what kinds of things do i think arise in
the future okay drone repairmen okay robotics
all the servicing of all the
stuff will be a big thing okay
lots of stuff related by medicine for example
general phlebotomist a phlebotomist somebody
no i mean some sort of chemist of some sort right
well it's somebody who takes your blood right okay
yeah so mobile phlebotomy i think is going
to become a really big thing why because
people can get blood tests on the go everywhere
right and that's way more convenient basically
you're going to the doctor and have them take
blood and do tests yeah okay you get like these
kind of data points right the problem is often
those data points are like extremely episodic
and really what you want is like a continuous
measurement just like your graph from your um
your website clicks or something like that you
just want whatsapp you wanted over time right
so mobile phlebotomy and that's just one
like sort of blue collar job within health um
you know hospice care as people age there's going
to be more of that um everything related to uh
you know babies and elderly people i think
will surge because that's the stuff that you
kind of want care you don't want a robot to do it
right and so you think that will be human that'll
be human interaction that's gonna be human uh i
think for a while until you can have an extremely
emotive robot that's very hard to do uh and all
the homeschooling push homeschool has increased
in search in a big way because there's these vogue
schools they're shut down you know teaching like
all the stuff so people are going to home schools
because it's better education and whatnot and then
they're realizing actually that you can separate
out at least for those kids beyond a certain age
you can separate out the babysitting component of
school right from the education component school
and you factor those out into essentially somebody
who is watching the kids and then like the super
advanced like learning apps that they're doing you
know so it's almost like they're supervising their
work on the learning apps so that's a relatively
low skill you know job that people can do yeah
i don't i'm saying nothing is bad but it's not
requiring computer science you know how to punch
some buttons on an app make sure the kids don't
hurt each other and you can be like the kind of
back to the future the the one room schoolhouse
you know the one room schoolhouse for like you
know 10 people right okay that's another job
that i think is going to surge let's call it it's
not exactly homeschooling by the way it's like
community schooling or community school teacher
or something like that right yeah um crowdfunding
community schools each other if you have a name
for this yet maybe we do maybe i haven't paid
attention but something like that okay other
things um biomedicine in general i think is gonna
soar and all the things associated with that um
i think uh you know like the entire
crypto supply chain of course is is coming
and you know that that's uh that's many
things um a lot of it is skilled of course
uh but you you've got the investing stuff that
i mentioned you'll have people also who are
doing data and putting data online like weather
reporting and so on for crypto oracles so that
people can quote make bets on uh like you know the
uh whether their field is going to get rained on
more of the future jobs i can project some of
them based on things like drones like robotics
crypto like bio um space is actually becoming
bigger you know so space mechanic that's becoming
bigger and bigger like people are able to launch
satellites um so a lot of the future that we were
promised is coming um electric car repairman blah
blah blah all those kinds of things construction i
actually think we're going to have a huge build
out in the middle of america in remote areas uh
because people will have houses in the middle of
nowhere because they want to kind of get away from
people and have kind of intentional communities
so i think that that's going to be a big area
so that's physical or at least supervising robots
okay and so on and so forth i think you know can i
pre which ones of these are going to be absolutely
massive hard to say okay uh i do think that um
like you know bio are pretty bullish on but
one of the things that's hard is sometimes
jobs like elevator operator you know they were
really big and they're really small and we don't
really think of them as jobs they're really
kind of you know small things or like taking
care of horses that was a huge thing not a big
thing anymore you know um so so that's some of
the things i think that people will do i know
that was a long answer but i'll yeah right so um
oh last thing number seven uh the hyper
deflation of cost if you remote work
okay so for anybody who can remote work or anybody
who can move can actually do really well in this
environment because they can arbitrage the
entire world right they can go to the place
the most suits them so even if physical prices
are rising they can bring those costs down
by using essentially a geographical search
engine to find the best place for themselves
to live and work so these are different ways
that you can kind of adapt to this coming world
um it's an incomplete list you can probably
sort yourself into those categories maybe
afterwards i'll look at the transcript and kind
of sort it a little bit more but those are some
of my thoughts go ahead yeah firstly wow that
was very very thought through um really really
really fascinating really interesting um i think
that i really thought the whole idea of everybody
becoming an investor is absolutely spot on um
you know i've got friends who aren't interested
in finance or anything like that and suddenly you
know now england's out of lockdown kind of um like
we meet up and everybody's sort of buying this
everyone's buying that and it's really shocking
and you also make an interesting point because
when i was younger everybody wanted to grow up and
be a singer a dancer or a footballer now everybody
wants to be a content creator and an influencer
major asterisk on the everyone wants to be
an investor things super super important
which is at the beginning of you know the weimar
hyperinflation everybody thought they were getting
rich you know mark was up all this prince of
money was out there there's so-called you know
cantaloupe where like people get that early
on everybody thinks of becoming millionaires
and new fortunes were created but the only people
who retained those fortunes were people who put
some or a big chunk of it into gold or other hard
currency remark right so i think that actually
this economy i actually do think um there's
essentially two drivers right one is the state
printing all this money which is going to cause at
some point like significant inflation it's already
starting um and so that will cause you know
bitcoin to rise so i definitely advise people who
are concerned about inflation buy bitcoin bitcoin
do not sell bitcoin hold your bitcoin right uh and
if you can learn how to hold your bitcoin locally
and auto exchanges but even if you can only buy on
exchanges you know uh do that right um yeah so
that's one and then number two is i actually do
think that we are moving into this digital first
world so i think that tech will continue to do
well in a fundamental way but i think that folks
who are not sophisticated investors or who are not
holding btc could very much lose their shirts in
this environment which will make people mad okay
um so i'm definitely not saying go out and gamble
your money or anything like that if you only buy
one thing by bitcoin um and uh you know bookmark
this okay if you're a sophisticated person you can
potentially be better than that but that's like
the no op you know yeah the golden one yeah no i'm
gonna say go on go go go go on the no op basically
means the action you take in the absence of
it's basically a computer instructions that says
don't do anything right buy bitcoin hold a bitcoin
and that's kind of your insurance policy and just
you just hold it you don't like you don't touch it
you don't look at the price every day uh you go
about your life because it's whatever percentage
of your net worth that you can essentially write
it off right but it's your insurance policy
um and uh so that will cause in some way some
disillusionment with everybody becomes an investor
and will polarize people against it but i think
it will also um kind of lead to that world because
bitcoin holders are investors in a sense right
they make a projection of the future there's
something else but i wanted to return to which
actually your point about yuri bessemenov and how
it's only sensed when there's a physical actuation
right okay so um in software we are able to
determine whether bits have been installed on a
machine right if you go and you right-click an app
uh you will see the signature and the certificate
which shows who developed it you know what website
it came from you can probably if you want to
figure out who the ceo that was and who the
software developers were and you know if it's
open source even you can go back and find the
lines of code that are running on your computer
right you can you can track origin okay and as
consequence of this is partly a consequence we can
do things like track download stats we can track
internet traffic we can see bittorrent and we can
see you know like smtp and these various protocols
on the web you can track website popularity ebb
and flow you can track all of these things okay
but we are not as good at tracking we're getting
better at it but we're not as good at tracking
is the not the code that is installed on hard
drives but the ideas that are installed in minds
okay so the thing is that um i'm trying to give
a okay here's a good example abolish the please
okay that snippet right those three words uh
you've heard it yeah great okay that's actually
like software that there was a slogan that was
developed by somebody and optimized uh it could be
effectively an emergent thing where you know
somebody said it and then other people modified it
and so on or it could be literally like a call to
arms actually a better example which we know was
developed was um occupy wall street and you know
the 99 right there's actually an article on you
know how they came up with the propaganda poster
this is like eight or nine years ago some of your
viewers may not remember it but um i think there's
ad busters in canada that came up with that here
to occupy wall street and the means and so on
and so forth and they push it out there right
and then millions of people are talking about the
99 of what percent that polarization that frame
that was effectively advertising marketing
collateral that was built by smart people
in conference rooms right or whatever it
was the ad buster's office is right and
so that's code that is executing
in your brain where you don't have
an origin for it right you it's not like software
it's not digitally signed you don't know where it
came from right uh most people aren't even
thinking about the fact that it came from
somebody in fact to see that it came for somebody
is considered conspiracy theory paranoia whatever
however with twitter you can actually root
cause and if you're good at twitter search
you can find who like the first person to say
something was right okay search.twitter.com you
can do basically look for keywords you can find
out like when does this meme originate right like
it's a digital thing where you can trace it
back memetic archaeology just like we trace
back the origins of covid or well that's a hard
one because china's yeah i was gonna say yeah
but let's say a virus in general you can one
that's not political and controversial you can
trace it back to where it came from right you
could trace back individual genes figure out
where they they came from right we can do the same
with memes we can trace them back now one issue is
that twitter makes this challenging because it's
a corporate database not everybody has access
to the so-called historical power search api in
fact very few people do uh that's an arcane api
which you need enterprise access to and twitter's
permission to look at all the tweets ever okay if
you could look at all the tweets ever you could
determine and when and who spread certain means
that eventually took over the world right who are
the initial promoters of it and so on and so forth
you can actually start getting ideological root
cause for at least anything that was spread on
unencrypted social media now this is what i'm
interested in like decentralized social media
um there's several platforms out there but the
key is that these things now have blockchains
where you can print out every single equivalent
of a tweet anybody can do so and so now you can
actually audit this and you can see the diffusion
of memes and we can sort of audit our information
environment see who's putting it out there and
like who are the initial circulators and you know
what conflict of interest they have or whatever
right um and you put basically an origin stamp
on that right i'm not saying necessarily to
attract attack the person sometimes the meme
is good or harmless or whatever right but i am
saying to understand you know did it come from
the wet market or did it come from a lab or did it
come from you know some like zoonotic leap these
are interesting things to know right okay going a
little bit further you know if you think about the
history of genetics right mendel uh you know came
up phenomenologically with the fact that uh you
know like the pea plants and the crosses like you
know big a little a if you remember that from you
know high school genetics he came up with some
of the laws you know mendel's laws of genetics
which are not full cost but they apply for you
know straight dominant recessive characters from
the dealing traits but he didn't know how that
actually worked biochemically he just observed
at a high level phenomenologically okay and uh you
know fischer and some of the other early genesis
had a different model for so-called quantitative
traits like height right and they had a model
where you know it would um it would be like more
like a bell curve rather than the zero one of
mendelian genetics it fell to later scientists to
determine okay the structure of dna in this sort
of so-called neo-darwinian synthesis which is the
molecular biology of the gene that's to say how
the gene could give rise to both the individual
mendelian characteristics as well as collectively
to things like okay why am i talking about
this because what remains to be done is for
us to figure out what the molecular neurology
of the meme is okay these memes float around
how are they stored how are they accessed how
are they represented how are they deleted how
are we vaccinated against them we have only
really the faintest understanding of this stuff
we're starting to get better at it with things
like neurolink but some of the work by you know
guys like nicholas going back 20 years on brain
machine interface um you know some of the work on
the so-called i think the jennifer aniston neuron
you know where specific memories or associations
of things appear to be stored in like particular
neurons like the jennifer aniston neuron famously
with light up not just when you heard about
jennifer anderson but you heard about friends
you know because she was on that show right and
we're also seeing things in artificial neural
networks that seem to have similar characteristics
which seem to recognize like the the concept of an
eight you know like not just the number eight but
it's spelled out eight um you know it's like eight
dots and so on and so forth we're starting to see
these kinds of things artificial neural networks
it's like you've got a brain of that you can
kind of poke and trigger and see this stuff right
once we understand better the molecular neurology
of the mean how means are stored and represented
once we understand better how to audit social
networks and decentralized media um i think
we'll understand better how to both promote and
vaccinate against you know bad means like vocalism
like communism we'll actually understand how to
deal with media corporations that are spiking
the equivalent of sugar into every story putting
you know the patriarchy or whatever into every
headline in order to sell copies um one way of
doing that for example is to have chrome plugins
that are decentralized where you can view all
the code but that auto read an article for you
and then highlight in red all the trigger words
that are meant to get you angry and that like auto
substitute right it's literally remember my thing
about the food taster and the the it's like that
for the untrusted environment media you're like
oh this guy actually spiked it with 15 rage words
that i might not have been aware of unless i had
seen these nutrition facts on the side which this
tap gives us right go ahead no that's interesting
um that was a lot of a lot of information um
no it was really really interesting um just to
think that we could move to a world where we
have those those trigger words um and people can
sort of decide for themselves you know whether
they want to go forward and indulge and you know
whether it is likely to purposely um either be
political or aggravate you or whatever it is but
these decentralized apps and i know that you're
really interested in these things like bitcloud
and whatever but i'm not gonna go into it because
time and everything but just on a last point i
know that decentralization um is obviously the
goal for a lot of people is for me to some extent
um but i i'm often quite skeptical about the
um how successful they will be right so like
people don't like youtube for example because
censorship twitter because of censorship
and all this stuff that we've spoken about
um of course you have competitors or equivalents
we have like uh lbry library which is supposed
to sort of be the decentralized version um you
know you've got a bit clout which is getting
a lot of wonderful facebook um again you're
knowledgeable about the space lbry you know
is good i'm an investor in that like you know
you know a lot of the technologies i'm impressed
i know i've seen your show before but you have
more you like you know some of the more obscure
things which i i think a lot of people in crypto
don't even know about now not to beat up an lvry
for watching i think it's actually quite good
but it hasn't yet been widely used but i think
it's actually it's starting to get traction as
a decentralized youtube um but i still think but
what i'm saying is i think that a lot of the
time the user experience is really unfriendly
um i don't really love youtube but i'm on it just
because i have to be on it this show is live on
youtube it's not going to be on lbry um library um
you know we have parlour which isn't decentralized
but it was supposed to be the
competitor and that obviously had issues
so i'm just wondering you know whether
we really will be able to get to a place
um whereby we have decentralized applications um
which brings the power back to the people you know
it takes away any um concerns about censorship
um again i'm not gonna get into it because of
time but i also think you know what happened
donald trump was awful um so in terms of the
user experience do you really think we're gonna
get to a place where everybody finally migrates
uh short answer yes but let me give a slightly
longer answer um so first is uh you know in tech
stuff doesn't work until it does just wins like
vertically right you know ethereum like had
like fits and starts and then just went totally
vertical d5 was hopefully kind of flat and went
vertical in 2020 when people figured it out defy
summer happened um you know virtual reality was
flat for a long time lots of fits and starts and
then oculus was just this huge leap forward um
you know people tried web band in the early 2000s
and the tech wasn't there and then 20 years later
instacart is massive right um you know things like
cosmo for delivering things in the early 2000s
uh late 90s that also was infeasible but then once
you had 100 billion build out of mobile phones
and so on the capital infrastructure was there and
then you could have instant delivery or everything
and so on and so forth there's lots of you know
ai you know we've been working on it for 50 years
things people thought were easy turned out to
be hard things people thought were hard some in
some cases turned out to be easier than we thought
chess turned out to be easier than driving a car
for example though most people wouldn't think of
it that way this is like more of x paradox i don't
know if you're aware of this but logical reasoning
is relatively easy for a computer what's hard
is sensor motor stuff like balancing driving and
things like that that requires massive computation
so the the thing about it the thing about
software in particular is when it works it
can just go whoosh totally vertical same
thing that's a sensor or an actuator the
robotic stuff that's harder because it's harder
it's harder to iterate on the cycles are slower
in that software in the decentralized software
when it works it will take off with no warning
beyond just following the space every you know
like like really closely and being like okay they
figured it out you figure out how to scale block
chains like actually if you look at polygon or
bsc you know scalability is now happening on
you know both ethereum and ethereum like chains
with some compromises yes but you know you've
got solana you've got avalanche you've got your
protocol you've got polka dot you've got
all these guys who are working on this so
uh that scalability then allows people to do more
sophisticated things a lot of cryptography by the
way that's involved with that let me actually make
a few comments on that just for a second okay just
as a plausibility thing for those of your audience
who know about error correcting codes if you send
n bits um and there might be an error in them the
obvious thing to do is just resend that message
over and over again and hope that you can kind of
do best of three and be like okay there's a bit
flip here and there it turns out that mathematics
you can actually do more like log base two of n
so if there's eight bits you don't have to send
it twice thrice you don't send 16 24 bits you can
just send another three bits like essentially the
error correction code bit why those three bits are
functions of the other eight uh and it turns out
there's corruption you can detect it and you can
ask for a resend only if there's a corruption
and so with advanced math you can achieve more
compression than people might otherwise
think a lot of the recent stuff with like
loop ring and zk roll ups and so on uses advanced
cryptography zero knowledge proofs and things you
know that are allied to achieve compression and to
actually get on you know on chain scalability now
does the average joe need to understand this no
no no more than they understand furry transforms
to pick up their phone okay but the math
is there the math is coming so i'm actually
bullish on the space in the long run let
me just say one other thing which is um the
with all of that said i think decentralization
is a tool but centralization is also a tool
the goal is to achieve good outcomes
decentralization basically allows us to
pull away our trust from institutions that try
to make it obligatory i don't have to trust the
us dollar right i don't have to trust you know a
wall street regulator i can go to another country
with a different regulator i don't have to
trust you know twitter or facebook if you
can have decentralized media right basically
though and this is a critical thing you know i
think it's a mistake to say it means trust no
one it means you have a choice of good trust
right civilization doesn't mean an absence
of leaders but an abundance of them
and so i think what will happen is given a choice
people will re-centralize around better leaders
it's not just getting back to the same place
though it's more like a corkscrew where there's
aspects of it they're the same place but hopefully
we're moving up along the z-axis towards better
leadership and so on over time that's how i think
about you know the unbundling and rebundling the
decentralization recentralization decentralization
that's just a cycle that happens in computing
it happens in history it happens in technology um
and i think it's also happening here with nations
and with states and so on yeah i certainly don't
think it's going to be one or the other and i even
think the rise of cbdc's which we haven't spoken
about but another time um i definitely think that
the rise of cbdc's definitely sort of shows that
because you have the option of well eventually
we'll have the option of bitcoin i don't think
that's ever likely to be banned um successfully um
and then you have cbdc so you know the existence
of decentralization versus centralization i think
will definitely exist um but just finally it's
been so fascinating hearing all this i knew
when i was putting questions together and topics
i was like i knew we would talk about a range of
different things um so just finally what are
you working on right now and how can people
follow your work and get involved great
question so i've got a site 1729.com where um
we're putting out like a newsletter for um tasks
and tutorials so learn crypto earn crypto also
burn calories we have a proof of workout thing um
this will relate to something i've been thinking
about which is um content that is aligned with
the viewer so as to say you read the content
and you actually have demonstrable approval
gains in either your portfolio or your learning
or your you know your weight or your muscle mass
or something like that and you're starting to be
aligned with the reader so you're not optimizing
page views you're optimizing the improvement
in the reader's lifestyle which has now become
feasible because you know we have fitbit we have
uh you know like crypto and so on and so forth
like what would men's health be in the era of
fitbit what would bloomberg look like if all the
news and content was scored against your portfolio
performance over time right so this is a thing i'm
thinking a lot about like what a healthy positive
sum content environment looks like and you know
if you define the metrics often you can define
the entire product because that's what you're
actually optimizing so that's the kind of thing
that's on my mind right now and i'm also writing a
book so go and subscribe to centralground.com it's
free put it out there you'll you'll hear you know
apology stuff if you want more yeah i think that's
really interesting being able to essentially just
provide content directly for the individual it's
not about the survival of whoever's providing
it like you know what would bloomberg look like
if it was aligned with people's portfolio
it's an interesting thought to be honest um
but biologists i want to thank you so much it's
been so so interesting um like i said i knew that
we would have so much to talk about so it's been
absolutely brilliant um thank you so much for
coming on and thank you everyone for watching
thank you okay speak to you soon take care bye
uh